let's get back to the phones and hear
from the most important people in the
David Pacman show Universe the audience
let's go to uh oh I don't know how about
Ramiro from Indiana welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
hey I had a quick question on uh I guess
comparing the U.S executive branch and
the way the system works in Argentina
um so the vice president that they had
the quote-unquote assassination attempt
recently so she had been the president
before yeah so in their system she can
become the I'm sorry yeah she was the
president
she can become the vice president
because here from my understanding like
Barack Obama would not be able to be the
vice president correct
so I don't remember the answer to that
in the U.S can if you've been president
you know I think you can be vice
president but if you if the president
were to die it would skip to the speaker
of the house maybe people can fact check
me on that yeah because at one point
there was the idea of Biden should pick
Obama as his uh as his VP
no that was actually an option but yeah
I'll have to look in on that that was
the only question I had
well uh how are things in Indiana
uh dude same as always I guess not great
not terrible and is everybody thrilled
that Mike Pence is back
well yeah well it's funny because
everyone in Indiana didn't like Mike
Pence until he became the vice president
ticket you know running mate so I don't
understand people are silly here right
all right well keep on keeping on all
right
all right thank you thank you very much
always great to hear from folks in
Indiana very powerful state